hello well I'm here to talk to you about
my animal news the sloth
I've been documenting the strange lives
of the world's slowest mammal for the
last ten years I still remember the
first time I saw one I was fascinated by
their freaky biology I mean what's not
to laugh about an animal that's born
with a fixed grin on its face and the
need to hug but sloths are massively
misunderstood
they've been saddled with a name that
speaks of sin and damned for their
languorous lifestyle which people seem
to think has no place amongst the
fittest in the fast-paced race for
survival well I'm here to tell you that
we've got this animal all wrong and how
understanding the truth about the sloth
may help save us and this planet we both
call home I traced softly slander back
to a Spanish conquistador called Valdez
who gave the first description of a
sloth in his encyclopedia of the new
world he said the sloth was the
stupidest animal that can be found in
the world I have never seen such an ugly
animal or one that is more useless tell
us what you really think Valdez I'd like
to have a word with about val versus
drawing skills
I mean what is that
I've never seen an illustration with
sloths that's more useless but I mean on
the plus side he has given the sloth of
remarkably human-like face and sloths do
have remarkably human-like faces this
sloth I photographed in Costa Rica I
think looks a lot like Ringo Starr but
then sloths to bear an uncanny
resemblance to the Beatles particularly
pleased with Paul actually on their like
the Beatles sloths are also extremely
successful they come from an ancient
line of mammals and they were once
dozens of species including the giant
ground sloth which was the size of a
small elephant and one of the only
animals big enough to eat avocado pits
whole and disperse them so some of you
have worked it out already that means
that without sloths there might be no
avocado on toast today leaving hipsters
everywhere totally bereft at breakfast
today there are six surviving species
and they fall into two groups you've got
your Brad a purse three-toed sloths
they're the ones with the Beatles
haircuts and the Mona Lisa smiles then
there are the two-toed sloths they look
a little bit more like a cross between a
Wookiee in a pig they live in the
jungles of Central and South America and
they're extremely prolific there was a
survey that was done in the 1970s in a
Panamanian tropical forest that found
that sloths were the most numerically
abundant large animal they took up one
quarter of the mammalian biomass now
that's an awful loss of sloth and
suggests they're doing something very
right indeed
so what if rather than dividing the
sloths for being different we tried to
learn from it instead we humans are
obsessed with speed busyness is a badge
of honor and convenience Trump's quality
in our quest for quick our addiction to
the express life is choking us and the
planet we idolized animals like the
cheetah the Ferrari of the animal
kingdom
capable of doing naught to 60 in three
seconds flat well so what
so what the sloth on the other hand can
reach a leisurely 17 feet a minute
with the wind behind it but being fast
is costly the cheetah is speedy but at
the expense of strength they can't risk
getting in a fight so they lose one in
nine kills - tougher predators like
hyenas no wonder they're laughing the
sloths on the other hand has taken a
more stealthy approach to dinner they
survived by capturing and consuming
static leaves but you see leaves don't
want to be eaten any more than antelope
do so they're loaded full of toxins and
very hard to digest so in order to
consume them the sloth has also had to
become an athlete a digesting athlete
the sloths secret weapon is a four
chambered stomach and plenty of time
they have the slowest digestion rate of
any mammal and it can take up to a month
to process a single leaf which gives
their liver plenty of time to process
those toxins so sloths aren't lazy no
they're busy digesting yeah really busy
hard at work nap sloth very hard at work
and of course Leafs have little
calorific values so sloths have evolved
to spend as little energy as possible
they do about 10% of the work of a
similar sized mammal and survive on as
little as a hundred calories a day
thanks to some ingenious adaptations the
Brad Icarus three-toed sloths they've
got more neck bones than any other
mammal even a giraffe which means they
can turn their head through 270 degrees
and graze all around them without having
to actually bother with the effort of
moving their body it also means that
they are surprisingly good swimmers
sloths can Bob along in water three
times faster than they can move on land
kept afloat by trapped wind so slots to
the early mammal that we know of that
don't do flatulence when they need to
expel gas it's actually reabsorbed into
their bloodstream and expelled orally as
a sort of mouth fart
[Laughter]
turning their lives upside down saves
further energy they have about half the
skeletal muscle of a terrestrial mammal
they don't really have so many of the
extensor muscles that are the
weight-bearing muscles instead they rely
on retractor muscles to pull themselves
along
they have long hooked claws and a high
fatigue resistance so they can literally
hook on and hang like a happy Harry
hammock for hours on end and sauce can
do almost anything in this inverted
position they sleep eat and even give
birth their throat and blood vessels are
uniquely adapted to pump blood and to
swallow food against the force of
gravity they have sticky bits on their
ribs that prevent their enormous stomach
from crashing their lungs and they've
got and their fur grows the opposite
direction so they can drip dry after a
tropical drenching the only problem is
if you turn a sloth the other way up
gravity removes its dignity they
literally they can't hold themselves
upright and so they drag their bodies
along as if mountaineering on a flat
surface and I think this is why the
early explorers like Valdez thought so
poorly of them because they were
observing sloths the wrong way up and
out of context I've spent many happy
hours mesmerised by moving sloths their
lack of muscle hasn't impeded their
strength or agility Nature's Zen masters
of mellow move like Swan Lake in slow-mo
with the core control of a Tai Chi
master this one has fallen asleep mid
move which is not uncommon
but you're probably wondering how does a
dangling bag of digesting leaves avoid
being eaten good question well this is
one of the sloths main predators it's
the harpy eagle it can fly at speeds of
up to 50 miles per hour has talons the
size of a grizzly bears razor-sharp
eyesight and that ring of feathers
focuses sound so that it can hear the
slightest leaf rustle the sloth on the
other hand has poor hearing bad eyesight
and running from danger is clearly not
an option no they survive by wearing an
invisibility cloak worthy of Harry
Potter their fur has grooves that
attract moisture and act as tiny
hydroponic gardens for algae and they
also attract a host of invertebrates so
they are their own slow-moving miniature
ecosystem they become one with the trees
and we think that their movements are so
slow they slip under the radar of the
monstrous harpy as its flying about the
canopy scanning for action sloths are
stealth ninjas and they rarely leave the
safety of the canopy except to defecate
which they do about once a week at the
base of a tree
now this risky and energetic behavior
has long been a mystery and there are
lots of theories as to why they do it
but I think they're leaving
surreptitious scented messages for
potential mates because you see sloths
are generally silent solitary creatures
except for when the female is in heat
she will climb to the top of a tree and
scream for sex in d sharp
don't believe me d sharp this and only
this note will get the male's attention
it mimics the sound of the Kiska d
flycatcher so the female remains covert
even when yodeling for sex at the top of
her lungs her clandestine booty calls
will carry for miles across the canopy
and males will beat a slow path towards
her I think scented messages in her dung
will help send Romeo up the right tree
submit he doesn't waste precious energy
scaling the wrong one sex by the way is
the only thing that's lost too swiftly
I've seen them do it in the wild and
it's over and done with in a matter of
seconds but then why waste precious
energy on it particularly after that
journey unlike other mammals sloths toad
also wastes time maintaining a constant
warm body temperature energy from the
Sun is free so they bask in the Sun like
lizards and we're an unusually thick
coat for the tropics to keep that heat
in sloths have a freakishly low
metabolism and we think that this might
be one of the reasons that they can
sometimes recover from injuries that
will kill most animals this sloth
recovered from a double amputation I've
see on I've known sloths that have
managed to survive even powerline
electrocutions and we now think that a
low metabolism may well be key to
surviving extinction
researchers at kansas university who is
studying mollusks found that a high
metabolism predicted which species of
mollusk had gone extinct sloths have
been around on this planet in one shape
or another for over 40 million years the
secret to their success is their slow
'full nature they are energy-saving
icons and I founded the sloths
appreciation society to both promote and
protect their slow steady sustainable
lives
I'm pretty speedy character I'm sure
you've guessed and the sloths have
taught me a lot about slowing down and I
think that the planet would benefit if
we all took a slowly digested leaf out
of their book how about we all embrace
our inner sloth by slowing down being
more mindful reducing wasteful
convenience being economical with our
energy recycling creatively and
reconnecting with nature otherwise I
fear it will be us humans that turn out
to be the stupidest animals that can be
found in the world thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]